after months of global grain shortage
negotiators in turkey say that they have
reached a deal to resume grain exports
from ukraine after hours of negotiation
in istanbul turkey's defense minister
announced ukraine and russia had agreed
to allow grain shipments through the
black sea turkey and the united nations
helped broker that deal expected to be
signed next week the deal would end a
months-long impasse that has left more
than 20 million tons of much-needed
grain stuck in ukrainian ports unable to
leave because of fighting in the country
now u.n secretary general antonio
guterres says that more work was still
needed to finalize the deal but hailed
the breakthrough as a critical step
forward
in a world darkened by global crises
today at last we have a ray of hope
a ray of hope to ease human suffering
and alleviate hunger around the world
a ray of hope to support developing
countries and the most vulnerable people
ray of hope to bring a measure of much
needed stability to the global food
system
ndw's nick connolly joins us now from
kiev nick
tell us just a few days ago the
ukrainian leadership said that it did
not trust russia with that in mind what
should we make of this breakthrough
well exactly that is the crucial issue
that trust is not there we've seen time
and time again deals to evacuate
civilians other deals uh between the
sides to talking about uh prisoners of
war and of uh
the kind of the bodies of casualties of
war all those deals have fallen through
time and time again so the question
about whether ukraine and russia can
work together now lots of question marks
there lots of doubts i think this is
definitely about the blame game
both sides in this conflict know that
this is an issue that has caught the
attention people around the world that
people are really feeling the impact of
this conflict
in their daily shopping in their in in
their their food bill and so they're all
trying to play a game they're all
showing willingness to engage but
whether ukraine really is willing to
take those minds away to basically
make cities like odessa and mikolai
vulnerable to russian attacks from the
sea to let those commercial
grain ships through i think there are
lots and lots of doubt still whether
that's actually going to happen they're
talking about some kind of coordination
center in turkey that would uh manage
shipping through the black sea but
people here on the ground analysts are
saying even if there were that
willingness to remove the mines that
still could take months because lots of
those mines were laid in a hurry in the
first few days and weeks of this war so
even even if despite all the odds that
kind of trust is somehow found the
realization might take a lot longer than
lots of people around the world are
hoping remind us what's at stake here
when it comes to grain shipment for
ukraine
well obviously this is a huge industry
lots of farmers here are basically
sitting on huge harvest that the world
desperately needs but they can't get
them out can't get paid for them um and
you know moving forward to the next few
harvests without that ready cash coming
in how are they going to pay their wages
how they're going to pay for fuel and
fertilizer but it's also about the
bigger point of ukraine's access to the
world oceans other industries like
metals
they're being able to get their exports
out the land borders are just a lot more
expensive in terms of the logistics
they're further away they're less well
organized so it's the bigger picture for
ukraine but actually i think in all this
in terms of the food this is more a
problem for the outside world than for
ukraine because paradoxically as long as
those ports stay closed food is actually
going to get cheaper here in ukraine for
ukrainian customers it's the people in
places like lebanon mauritania often
very far away who are incredibly
dependent on ukraine not only for grain
but also for vegetable real basics that
are just exploding in price right now
okay so so many knock-on effects for the
global community dw's nick connolly for
us there in the ukrainian capital kiev
thank you so much
you